oh hello may I speak to brown kobilka
please oh hello this is Adam Smith I'm
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize
uhm we have a tradition of recording
extremely short interviews with new
laureates could we speak for just a very
few minutes sure thank you I know it's
the middle of the night there first of
all sincere congratulations on the award
thank you I imagine the household was
asleep when the call came who took the
call did you did you get it well the
first call I think didn't get answered
they keep trying and and what what are
one's initials thoughts on getting that
call I thought it was I thought it was
some friends initially but I don't have
friends that a really good Swedish
accent oh then I started believing it
and do you feel that do you feel this is
an utter surprise so so you've been
awarded the prize for your studies on
g-protein coupled receptors and since
the 80s when you joined the Lefkowitz
lab you've been trying to disentangle
the structures of those receptors for
those who've never seen one could you
describe what they look like their
beauty that's really does I'm trying to
think of something in nature that I
could you know could use as an example
but there really isn't any you know any
thing that you encountering in a day
that you could say it's a good model for
it but to be able to see it for the
first time it was really amazing in
three dimensions and so that was
probably that there were there are times
when you see some of the structures that
we've got in particular
the one last year where you see
everything together and how it works
together was really you know really very
satisfying so this is the entire complex
together with the g-protein attached and
the ligand in place yeah that's an
amazing feat I mean it took so many
years to get to that point and many I
think felt that it was or an almost
impossible task what kept you going I
don't know it was just something that I
really wanted to see and I had you know
a great group of colleagues working on
it we were all excited about doing it
and you know we just kept making
incremental improvement in what we were
doing and finally we succeeded I mean
she said it was a you know it was a
really a group effort a lot of people
involved it was very very exciting
project strangers these receptors are
normally said to mediate the actions of
about half the medicines we take and yet
nobody really knows about them it's
amazing we're full of them and they're
so important but rather unknown yes and
we don't really know how to control them
very well yet so even you know the
medicines still aren't perfect they have
side effects some of these are because
targeting for one receptor they're still
kind of promiscuous and though they'll
bind to another type of GPCR so we still
have quite a ways to go before we can
really take advantage of what we know
about them in terms of therapeutic now
you're a notoriously self-effacing
person and quite a quiet person I gather
how do you feel about the prospect of
the deluge of press attention that's
about to arrive looking forward to that
I mean you tend to avoid the limelight
as far as I know maybe you can minimize
the impact you've been awarded with Bob
Lefkowitz with whom so you worked in the
80s and in a way you're very different
characters how did the two of you mesh
together together very well in fact
we're still we speak on a regular basis
and in fact we're just starting to put
together a paper that our groups have
been collaborating on a project for a
couple years and we we've gotten some
made some progress and so yeah
I mean he was a fantastic mentor and you
were we are quite different but you know
I think sometimes that works out well
yeah it's a marriage of Oprah opposites
and I couldn't be happier for him
it's a lovely pairing really really nice
just one last thought the field of
structure solving in GPCRs it's quite a
competitive one people racing to get to
the first structures again how does one
deal with the competition element of it
I don't know that I don't know how much
it affects you you when you have a goal
you obviously want to be the first their
scientists are sometimes as competitive
as professional athletes maybe but like
you can't worry about it too much or
it'll distract you from your goal so and
I'm not sure how us what else to say
about that but if you really want
something bad enough if you're really
interested in something enough you just
keep working on it
thank you that's a lovely answer just
personally I just wanted to say that
once when I was the editor of Nature
Reviews drug discovery you contributed
beautifully to some GPCR features we
were doing so it's a particular pleasure
for me individually to be speaking to
you now the collection of comment that's
right that's right it was the state of
GGC our research like in 2000 that
effect it was quite a bit before we got
the structure but yeah so when you said
someone did you have yourself in mind or
were you not that well I hoped it would
be me but we didn't have any there's a
difference between yes certainty I
suppose and confidence because you seem
to remain confident in the ability to
get somewhere even though you weren't
certain you'd make it that's true I
think I was somewhat confident I think I
had worked on it long enough I think I
knew the protein really well so somehow
I mean I think if you've got to believe
you can do it otherwise it's you know
it's sort of a struggle because you have
to you know get funding and keep the lab
going and so you have to believe in
yourself well it's been a great pleasure
to speak to you and I can picture the
scene presumably all the family is now
up as well my wife
and and the kids have heard of that and
we have to tell you you know I have a
one of the rare marriages where my wife
and I have been working together in the
lab for I mean ever since I was in the
left quits lab and and we still you know
she still we still work together so it's
it's particularly you know satisfying
because you know she shares a lot of the
credit for my success in the field and
so I feel like I'm sharing it with her
as well oh that's lovely that's really
nice
I suppose the Nobel Prize is always a
family prize but this makes it even more
so lovely the kids are aware but are
they going to go back to sleep or what
do they do well my kids are my
daughter's gonna turn 29 tune in my son
is 31 so they're not here at the house
with us but yeah we text texted them in
and they woke up and they called it
though okay sleepless people all over
the states now yeah all right well when
you come to Stockholm in December we
have a chance to interview you a greater
length and I very much look forward to
that